So there's some beautiful pieces
that goes, actually, it's huge.
It's six volumes,
and it's called
the Atlas of Haitian Creole.
It's online, so I'd be happy to
share the reference with you.
I mean, actually, it has maps.
It also has recordings.
You can actually go and
listen to the various dialects
of Haitian creole.
And what people have
found striking is
the fact that, in
terms of variation,
it's quite restricted, so
anywhere you are in Haiti,
you can speak to someone
who speaks Creole.
You can speak Creole.
So there are some words that
are kind of-- shibboleth
of seven regions,
but overall there
is no issue with
misunderstanding.
You know, Asians
understand each other
when they speak creole
even though, at first, it
might be a bit of
hesitation if you come
from two different regions.
And that atlas actually
documents that very well--
that you have lots of lexico
idiosyncrasies across regions,
but the grammar itself
is pretty much similar,
which one might
think, it's surprising
given that you have all
this influx of Africans
in various language groups.
You'd expect more variation,
but people have also
argued, given the
fact that, if you
look at the history of
Haiti, the country was
for a long time pretty
isolated after independence.
In fact, that's something
that we can talk about later.
The European forces and
the American forces,
even though Haiti helped the US
in terms of its independence,
getting more territory--
like, I don't
know if you've heard about
the Louisiana purchase which
was caused because of
Napoleon losing Haiti,
because of Haitian Revolution.
But yet, the US quarantined
Haiti very quickly, why?
Because Haitian was an example
of black liberty, which
was a threat to the
world back then.
Haiti was unthinkable
and unacceptable,
so it had to be embargoed.
And that embargo,
people have argued
is what actually created this
isolation that, in turn, gave
Haitian creole pretty
much it's uniformity,
because there was little
traffic from outside to Haiti.
For a long time, Haiti was
pretty much self-contained,
and that helped the
language gel as, you know,
a pretty uniform system.
AUDIENCE: And was it
always uniform over time?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Well, over
time, the data is not so--
we don't have enough
data to document
that, whether over time, there
was more or less variation.
Because what we have
is pretty fragmentary.
We don't have lots and lots
of evidence about, say,
18th century Haitian creole.
We have some
archival data but not
enough to be able to
compare what happened
in different regions of the
country, but what we do have,
going to the 17th,
18th century--
you know, strike us as pretty
similar to the Haitian-spoken
now.
So there were French scholars
who were writing down
what they would hear.
They were writing down a
variety of Haitian creole
from the 18th, 19th century,
and I can still read those text.
Of course, they were written
with French autography,
and maybe that's
another confound.
They were probably imposing
their French onto the creole
that they were transcribing,
but if you read that creole back
then, the structures are pretty
similar to the creole of today,
which also is striking
as compared to English,
which has evolved much faster.